hi how many gigabyte or terabyte will
you be able to put in a mp3 in like five
years okay today there are some discs
with the capacity of 500 gigabytes and
sis husband to a density of information
of about 500 also gigabyte gigabits per
in square and this is done with the
technology of TMR tunneling
magnetoresistance for the heads and what
I know about the project of several
companies at the simulation will use the
CPP gmr that is a giant
magnetoresistance with the current
perpendicular to the layer with after
three or four years and increase by a
factor of four or five that means that
with this increase it will be able to do
to get disc with a capacity of about two
two terabytes a poor little mermaid